what's happening reject nation we're
going to watch from our friends today
new rock stars
marvel x-men the mcu x-men debuting in
shang chi full bracket revealed excited
to check this out eric voss always has
the best of theories
and breakdowns and i'm just now
realizing i'm still wearing a dc
shirt what the [ __ ]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss in marvel studios shang chi and the
legend of the ten rings is one of the
more closer arabian mcu films that is
also a huge mystery we did explore the
fighting tournament plot from the set
visuals in australia but
now production has surprisingly moved to
san francisco
giving us some limited but telling
footage that might actually reveal a lot
about this plot and how it entitled
the broader mcu many of us noticed how
weak great time to block off roads
during lockdown
pretty significant shift of bumping up
shang qi
from the number three film spot to the
number two film phase four
leap frogging eternals to come out on
july 9th
of next year a move that confirms one
thing at least that marvel
is committed
tournament film especially with rumors
that many marvel familiars are going to
be joining
this tournament let's fill in the
bracket and break it all down spoiler in
case you don't want to know but you do
okay quick refresher is marvel's martial
arts badass baseball directly on the
popularity of bruce lee in the early 70s
singer lou is playing shang chi with
tony young playing the true mandarin the
head of the terrorist network that tony
stark crossed paths with in the iron man
movies
it's really no secret at this point that
shanxi is going to be following that
fight tournament plot of bruce lee
movies like enter the dragon
which was lee's final film role but one
of his most iconic the latest news comes
from the streets of san francisco many
local citizens sharing
images from the film set which shows an
apparent high-speed chase
through the city's streets involving an
articulated city bus that bendy bus
must get severed at some point because
other footage shows it creeping down the
street
[Music]
that was sectioned off with the pavement
just cracked into rubble
was it ant-man in san francisco
some other footage of construction
workers fleeing this scene
in fear perhaps a monster from below
oh and uh patriotic by the way if you
are interested in fixing this country's
crumbling infrastructure a great way to
let our leaders know
is by voting in person on november third
or early by mail
already voted if it's for you just do it
in our party
that geographically places all of this
in or
around sf's historic chinatown district
okay so
beyond enter the dragon a secondary
cinematic influence that i think we are
seeing here
is a certain cult classic starring a
certain ensu celestial kurt russell
in big trouble in little china dragon
stars bruce lee is a fighter in an
international tournament with various
quirky participants hosted by a wealthy
criminal
big gerbil little china is a bonkers 80s
action comedy about a trucker getting
sucked into an insane plot involving
ancient wizards and supernatural san
francisco's chinatown if it's so good
in shanghai's case this chaos we're
seeing in chinatown i believe is
either a set up to or a consequence of
the fighting tournament plot maybe the
second act of that film yeah
some familiar marvel faces and others
who will be important to marvel's future
which seems to be tying in
every phase four property black widow
doctor strange two
thor four goblins soldiers blade maybe
even an empty
deadpool so we have speculated how shang
chief will send around this
international fighting tournament hosted
in this case by the mandarin with the
prize of this ancient tournament being
the 10 rings of power and this latest
rumor suggests the mandarin might have
stacked the deck in the tournament to
guarantee the winner of those rings will
be his champion
so imagine a bracket here with 16 open
spaces
a sweet 16 that winnows down to an elite
eight then to a final four and then to
the top two in the final match but
before we fill
all these slots in look i know there's a
lot of clues because hair change
because the best visual clues are hiding
in plain sight just
like someone's front pocket wallet like
the ridge
ridge
[Laughter]
ridge help them promote richness great
company great products
oh my god you won't be able to kill your
credit cards
this is their aluminum silver wallet
including some very flashy tiki designs
this thing is light it's strong
just like that they make it easy to buy
with free shipping and free returns and
a
lifetime guarantee i got thirty thousand
five endorses
this endorsement they also have great
backpacks and travel
i approve this they do it's in the
option i can detest
this is a great background in return
use their promo code new rockstars and
use the code
new rockstars link in the video's
description
maybe aquafina's character though that's
not confirmed both of them in the comics
are children to fu manchu
the older comic villain who didn't
really age well and many believe marvel
is right
don't agree with that identity according
to these rumors the first spot
would be taken by mordo from the doctor
strange movie
his mission being to gain the ten rings
to help him rid the world of sorcerers
would be taken by clive reston an mi6
agent shang chi works with in the comics
and then wong from therefore
would stick around to council shang chi
another slot rumor has it is going to be
taken by
a black widow agent named felicia oh
cool you're one of those
many black widow agents that we meet in
black widow and probably someone we very
quickly say bye to ah
now another rumor repeats it's
george st pierre's villain to captain
winter soldier who apparently
is returning the falcon winner soldier
wow that thunderbolts fly
that guy's coming back
no characters to investigate and compete
in this tournament maybe a member of
asgardia
but the big one in this rumor is omega
red arkady rosevich sometimes considered
the russian wolverine
this guy's got long retractable medical
tentacles made of carbonadium
which was the product of soviet attempts
to make adamantium
you might see some parallels here with
red guardian alexis showstoko david
harper's russian cap coming in black
widow
i think that's by design because don't
be surprised if that prison facility
alexi busts out of in black widow also
unleashes characters like omega red
could also tie and backtrack the leaper
as well as felicia
i have speculated in the past that that
facility could also contain other
russian mutants like
peter and iliana rasputin colossus and
his sister that'd be crazy but rumored
taking another tournament
slot would be another mutant the six
armed spiral
rita hayward often associated with long
shot the x-men psylocke we're also
hearing maybe whiz kid
described as a techno mutant and then
t-ray a zombie kind of villain
associated with deadpool in the comics
damn this is like a mortal kombat anime
movie
and you've got someone with six arms to
a character from the 50s marvel kid
called
outlaw comics and then a vampire named
avoc which could tie in mahershala
blade film now this rumored report
leaves the rest of the slots open to
other warriors maybe
other mutants that marvel wants to talk
well no just those two
really the exciting element about these
tournament participants isn't the
character names themselves
it's the section of the marvel world
that they come from and what that tells
us
about where the mcu will expand next
like for example the mutants omega red
and whiz kid tell us that marvel might
be
implying mutants already exist in this
universe and we're about to meet a lot
more of them
and a lot of these mutants are real fun
to watch in the ring sabertooth
nightcrawler yeah wolverine but
separately we have been hearing from
different rumors that the
dragon thin bang boom will appear awoken
by this tournament
now thin fangboom is the ancient dragon
from shangchi and comics partner to the
mandarin coming actually from the same
alien star system that the 10 mcluhan
rings hail from we've been waiting to
see this thing come up in the mcu and i
believe it is totally possible we will
see this thing wreak havoc but not in
china
in america which brings us back to
what if the rubble those construction
workers are fleeing from is the
emergence of the sleeping dragon finn
fangroom
under the streets of chinatown that
bendy bus what if that's just real
construction
what if they just couldn't shoot right
there that would be the big trouble in
the little china finale i'm deep down
praying about your efficiency
mix of the hilly streets of chinatown
along with some horrifying cosmic
mythology really between that and giant
scott lang he can never throw enough at
this
city who else do you want to see in that
10 rings tournament bracket and how
would you play out the match
with me on new rockstar's official
discord server by becoming a patron
cyclops storm professor x professor x
[Music]
i mean we've talked about shanxi uh in
the past obviously
you know it just has a little refresher
on what's currently excited us that's
brought up in this video is like under
the dragon is one of the martial arts
movies i grew up on
other video games like mortal kombat and
tekken and video games can borrow that
similar type of like tournament format
people coming together
having the wide range of abilities in
terms of like some anime
i've recently watched i i got through
the the tuning exam
on naruto which really allowed for a
tournament-like style fighting bracket
where you got a wide display of fighters
with
unique types of superpowers essentially
so everything this movie is shaping up
to be at least from the announcements
it's getting me really excited for its
martial arts sequences
it won't just be you know kung fu
fighting it won't just be martial art
it'll also be implementing uh
the super powers there so you have to do
a lot of unique choreography with that i
feel like a lot of people might be going
like
it sounds like mortal kombat yeah it
does it sounds like mortal kombat more
like anime and
better with a plot light or something
like uh like an enter the dragon so far
but what i find especially clever about
all this
a lot of these guys haven't been
confirmed i mean a lot of them are
theorized but some of them have been
confirmed based off of the wikipedia
they're
tying it into other movies but i think
it's cooler that they're using like
more minor characters characters who
like the guy from
i'm already forgetting his name the guy
from like uh winter soldier
oh yeah forgot about that dude oh yeah
the other russian yeah
all these russian villains but by using
them as ways to tie in all the other
movies that
serve as tie-in to the bigger mcu
properties but also as like fun easter
eggs it works on a variety of levels
and allows them to showcase more of the
minor
characters as well people who probably
wouldn't get their own standalone movies
or be
main supporting characters but have an
opportunity to still
shine and show off a little bit that's
what
really excites me about implementing
them and like yeah including a couple of
mutants here or there people from the
x-men world
maybe not as a as an outright way of
saying x-men are here now
but as a way to you know elude or set
up or a hint more towards yeah the x-men
are coming
more powerful people out there yeah one
way or another whether we dissect
why or not in this movie i really like
just the idea of what they're going for
here and again marvel being you know at
the forefront of taking various genres
and crashing them into their superhero
stuff the fighting martial arts movie
the tournament movie
isn't a genre that has been served in a
long time i feel like and so
as nostalgia grows i think it's also
important to look back to the places
that aren't as obvious and for
a movie like this to have the idea that
we might go back at least
maybe to that type of structure is
actually really exciting because it
seems like we would get a marvel movie
that looks and feels very specifically
different
as much as i have been in throughout
these
uh you know news rumors and stuff not
wanting the x-men to come in too
fast i do think that having something
like this where yeah you might have
mordo
over here you might have some of the
other familiar auxiliary characters and
stuff and you have some x-men
that seems like a really natural way to
do it in a way where you know we
have a couple familiar characters that
help us to be acclimated because this is
going to be one of the new movies
we'll have a couple things to get people
excited for the future and then you know
shang chi hopefully can shine
amid all that stuff yeah so this is
pretty exciting to me i think
uh what black panther did in terms of
representation of like african culture
blade was the first he's actually like
the big catapult of superheroes
generally speaking well black panther
different mcu i'm hoping
shane she can do that for uh in asian
culture
as well and maybe taking the piss out of
it a little bit if they are
you know riffing on like big trouble
little china
you know taking place in san francisco
chinatown if they are able to like
poke fun at that especially how like
they that big trouble little china
embraced
some of those like asian stereotypes
that were often on display in movies and
like some people might be like oh
that's that's offensive but i if you
watch that movie i kind of feel like
it's intentional
it's supposed to be something that's
making fun of that
as well it seems like it has a knowing
quality to its pulpy camp
yeah yeah and then with the inclusion of
like a fu manchu like character which
has an age well hell even which has been
even the uh you know
first vision and for many years the
vision of mandarin
you know of how that was not really well
represented
and and like they're going to be
reworking these characters i think
making
fun at that type of period in hollywood
history maybe not like a big focal point
but it's something that riffs on it a
little bit
yeah you know yeah especially you know
because you have a production that is
being shepherd by so many people in the
asian community as creatives and stuff
like that i would almost hope that there
could be
at least a little bit of that cathartic
self-awareness because you know this
shouldn't be as monumental of a moment
as it is
yeah yeah yeah and then also getting the
dragon included
in san francisco it's funny man i like i
used to complain a lot about how i don't
feel like we have that many l.a
superheroes it's all in new york
yeah and you know and then i know iron
man 3 was at uh hollywood boulevard
man's chinese theater
then ant-man had a lot in uh in san
francisco and then now
putting this in san francisco it sounds
cool i like the architecture a lot of
san francisco i'm actually surprised
we're filming in san francisco right now
with the crazy fires they've been having
and everything and yeah the fact that we
saw a major lockdown out in calif in
california like we still have lockdown
i know other parts of the us it's not as
strict as it has been like out here
and in new york uh so you know while
it's like loosen up a little bit here
and there
i'm still oh well i mean especially in
san francisco i'm kind of surprised
they're
filming but it actually also works for
their benefit because people have to
stay indoors
more people have to stay home so less
traffic on the roads out there so
maybe shutting down the streets and
taking advantage of the time to shoot
out there now
really works for their benefit of like
less people have to be on the road right
now let's do this san francisco those
are busy roads so you just
you close off one of those streets man
you're looking at chaos you know the
angry temple people watching them like
swinging this bus around and stuff like
damn
if this was not lockdown time i can
imagine how how people would be pissed
at marvel right now
in san francisco for shutting down their
streets maybe shooting somewhere else
entirely
yeah all right guys well shane chin
legend of 10 rings you excited about
this information are you excited at the
thought of possibly them starting to
include mutants
kicking it off here with shane chi leave
your thoughts down below
subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so already hey what's your
subscribe button click our notification
bell hit that like button as well last
but not least patron of the day shout
out
niraj krishnan now niraj we keep wanting
more representation in these comic book
movies buddy
be there more women more people of color
we got the world of like black panther
in there we're getting shane chi with
some asian people
now i know you must be clamoring
to get some more indian representation
in there
so niraj i think it's time you start
bulking up you start hitting the gym
where you can in the east coast you
start getting shredded right now
that way you can audition for when they
finally get their first
real indian superhero that could be you
that's what i'm hoping for man you could
you i mean you're already almost
peter parker you got the glasses you got
the good nature now all you need is a
few
muscles and uh you know maybe a few
lessons in ass hickory and i could see
you really doing some cool things
you got the looks get it done just go on
the streets and be a vigilante for real
don't wait for the movies to catch up
yeah man like tom holland was showing
off his gymnastic skills and that really
helped him get the
role of spiderman so if i were you i'd
go out on the streets and start
murdering some people kicking some mass
taking out some bad guys that could
really work to your favor
and record it anyway bud love you man
we'll talk to you soon